Clean my room with me. I am 22 weeks pregnant,
and I am just starting to get my spark back,
just starting to get some more energy and some more good days.
Before you come at me for not keeping my room clean while I'm pregnant,
let me tell you that my heart rate was 160
while I was cleaning this room.
So that's on a good day. Anyway,
aside from that, I've just had so many clothes go up dirty and clean
and, you know,
that in between stage that just needed to be put away
and drawers that just got super messy that needed to be organized.
So it was so good to finally be able to clean up this room.
My husband and I both cannot stand the mess,
but this pregnancy has really thrown us for a loop,
so my little Darcy belly.
Anyway, so happy to get this room clean
and put away some new clothes that I bought
that are maternity friendly.
And then I'm giving it a final
quick vacuum with my little handheld vacuum.
I love this thing so much.
And then are you ready to see the finished result?
Cozy, tidy, beautiful. I love it.